DEADLY BLIZZARD.
A LIFE SAVED THANKS TO THE
KINDNESS OF A STRANGER.
"360'S" GARY TUCHMAN HAS THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: THE WORST OF MOTHER
NATURE, BRINGING OUT THE BEST OF
HUMAN NATURE.
THIS IS BUFFALO RESIDENT SHAKIRA
AUTRY ON FACEBOOK LIVE.
>> I CURRENTLY HAVE AN OLDER
64-YEAR-OLD WHITE MAN IN MY
HOUSE.
I FOUND HIM YESTERDAY.
I HEARD HIM SCREAMING FOR HELP.
>> Reporter: IN THE MIDST OF
WESTERN NEW YORK'S BLIZZARD
SHAKIRA SPOTTED AND HEARD THE
MAN IN TERRIBLE PAIN IN THE
FRIGID COLD OUTSIDE HER HOUSE ON
THE MORNING OF CHRISTMAS EVE.
HER BOYFRIEND CARRIED THE MAN
INSIDE.
THAT MAN IS JOEY WHITE, SEEN IN
THIS PICTURE IN A TORONTO BLUE
JAYS BASEBALL GAME.
>> HE GOT AWAY FROM HIS HOME --
THAT HE HE LIVES IN A GROUP HOME
HE TOLD ME.
>> Reporter: JOEY'S SISTER SAYS
HER BROTHER IS MENTALLY SXHAJD
DOES INDEED LIVE IN A GROUP
HOME.
HE WORKS AT A MOVIE THEATER AND
MAY HAVE GOENT SCARED DURING THE
BLIZZARD AND TRIED TO WALK HOME
GETTING LOST IN THE HEAVY SNOW
OUTSIDE THE MOTHER OF THREE'S
HOUSE.
SHAKYRA DID HER BEST TO COMFORT
HIM AND FEED HIM AND PLEADED FOR
HELP IN PHONE CALLS AND ON
FACEBOOK LIVE.
>> THIS MAN IS NOT ABOUT TO DIE
OVER HERE ON 111.
Y'ALL NEED TO GET THIS MAN SOME
HELP.
>> Reporter: BUT HER
NEIGHBORHOOD WAS VIRTUALLY
IMPASSABLE.
CHRISTMAS EVE BECAME CHRISTMAS
DAY.
JOEY WAS IN IMMENSE PAIN WITH
SEVERE FROSTBITE ON HIS HANDS.
>> JOE.
LISTEN TO JOE.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING, JOE?
JOE READY TO GO.
HE READY TO GO.
HE NEEDS TO GO BECAUSE HE NEEDS
MEDICAL ATTENTION.
I HAD TO -- HE HAD A RING ON HIS
FINGER.
I HAD TO USE THESE TO CUT THE
RING OFF OF HIS FINGER.
I'M NOT NO SURGEON.
>> Reporter: WITH HER THREE
CHILDREN BY HER SIDE SHA'KYRA
TRIED TO COMFORT JOEY.
>> JOE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU FEELING BETTER?
ARE YOU TRYING TO FEEL BETTER?
PARDON ME?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DIE.
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DIE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT DEATH.
SEE, THIS IS HOW YOU KNEE HE
NEEDS HELP.
>> Reporter: AND THAT HELP WAS
ABOUT TO COME.
GOOD SAMARITANS SHOWING UP IN A
VEHICLE THAT CAN MAKE IT THROUGH
THE SNOW.
JOEY WAS ON HIS WAY TO THE
HOSPITAL.
>> I'M RIGHT HERE, JOE.
>> Reporter: AND SHA'KYRA RODE
WITH HIM.
>> I'M RIGHT HERE.
ARE YOU OKAY?
I LOVE YOU TOO, SWEETIE.
YOU'RE OKAY.
>> Reporter: JOEY ARRIVED AT THE
HOSPITAL SAFELY.
>> THIS MAN COULD HAVE DIED.
64 YEARS OLD.
COULD HAVE DIED OUTSIDE.
I WASN'T GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN ON MY WATCH AND HE WASN'T
GOING TO DIE IN FRONT OF MY
KIDS.
>> Reporter: JOEY HAS SEVERE
FROSTBITE AND IS IN THE ICU IN
THE HOSPITAL BURN UNIT.
HIS SEVERE YVONNE TELLING US
IT'S TOUCH AND GO WHETHER HIS
HANDS CAN BE BE SAVED.
BUT OVERALL HE'S IN STABLE
CONDITION.
AND SHE IS SO GRATEFUL FOR
SHA'KYRA AUTRY.
>> THIS WOMAN DID SOMETHING THAT
AN ANGEL WOULD DO.
OKAY?
TO TAKE IN A PERFECTLY -- A
STRANGER.
A STRANGER.
YOU TOOK HIM IN IN YOUR HOME ON
CHRISTMAS EVE.
>> Reporter: JOEY WHIT